okay the world's two biggest economies
are the United States and China the
United States and China are also now in
a trade war thanks to Donald Trump and
what I want to prepare you for is a
bunch of the stuff that you buy
regularly getting much more expensive as
you might remember the Trump
administration previously announced
tariffs on China those went into effect
on Friday and there are new tariffs now
on thirty four billion dollars in
Chinese products China immediately
retaliated with thirty four billion
dollars in tariffs on American products
five hundred and forty five different
goods targeted by China long list beef
seafood dairy not concerning for the
vegans I guess but also farm goods
including this is going sow beans are
actually a big part of what's going on
with the tariffs and vegan Pat is going
to be very very concerned about that
cars another tariffed item this isn't
good for American workers the Chinese
people buy a ton of stuff from Nike and
Apple and Starbucks vehicles from
General Motors a lot of them
manufacturing for the American companies
does happen in China but these are in
the end American companies that are
going to be hit so on the one hand
you've got Chinese tariffs on the US
that's going to hurt American workers
then on the other hand American tariffs
on Chinese stuff are going to make
Chinese products more expensive for
American workers this is not good for
American workers Trump promised he was
just going to be great for American
workers and this is just the first 34
billion from Trump we know that there is
potentially another 16 billion
kind of in process and Trump has
threatened as much as 450 billion
dollars in tariffs and I've been ranting
and raving to you about the short-term
impacts of these tariffs for a while you
know them by now the question I'm now
thinking about and I was reading about
over the weekend is how does this end
what's the endgame here Trump claims
that the tariffs are because China is
unfair to the United States on trade and
is stealing intellectual property
okay those are specifics so are you
putting the tariffs in and then
negotiating to fix those problems do
Trump's advisers even agree on what the
solution to those problems would be hint
they don't agree on what the path
forward is and just as sort of like a
vignette of what is going on American
businesses that deal in soybeans for
example soybeans are a big part of how
these tariffs are just gonna be
absolutely disastrous soybean farmers in
the US and the Midwest are already
delaying buying equipment and making
investments in their own businesses so
the way it works is Trump tariffs China
China tariffs American soybeans the
American soybean farmer says well I'm
going to delay buying a John Deere
tractor so now Trump's China tariffs
hurt John Deere in the United States as
well and meanwhile the exact same thing
is happening with Canada Canada has done
the same they have now made effective
twelve point six billion in tariffs on
the u.s. retaliating because of American
tariffs on Canada exactly who we want to
be hostile with Canada right that's
really gonna work out well for us and
I'll remind you Trump said trade wars
are good and they're easy to win
well then win it I'm ready to win this
thing Pat well how long is that going to
take yeah you were talking about the
endgame I really wonder what Trump
thought these other countries would do
just to roll over and take these tariffs
I know he he wanted to make it up as you
know because he thought there were these
trade deficits with all these countries
that we had and he was just making up
for those but those countries don't see
it that way and they do Canada in
particular we have a trade surplus with
them and let's talk about Canada as an
example here's a wake up call at this
point that we all need we are talking
about can Democrats take over the House
and Senate in November if so can Trump
be defeated in 2020 we'll be able to get
back on track it's gonna take a long
time to fix the damage that has been
done to these relationships with
countries like Canada as Pat is pointing
out the meaningless executive orders can
be undone the positions that Trump just
isn't filling you can get those filled
pretty quickly as soon as you get a
competent administration but the damage
that's being
at the geopolitical level and to the
environment by this administration is
going to take a long time to undo in the
best case scenario and if Democrats
don't win in November and particularly
if Donald Trump wins re-election in 2020
we're talking about possibly decades to
undo the damage that is being done here
decades you know what the end game is
with the tariffs please let me know
because I've not been able to get any
straight answers from anybody at this
point today's program sponsored in part
by Indo Chino the largest custom apparel
company they make suits and shirts to
your exact measurements for a great fit
high quality selection of fabrics you
can personalize all sorts of options
like the lapel the jacket lining the
monogram and more I recently went to the
Boston showroom of Indo Chino I needed a
new suit I had the audacity after seeing
President Obama's great leadership on
the issue of tan suits to get myself a
tan suit and I got it at Indo Chino I
worked with Chris we took measurements I
selected my fabric I chose my
customizations and then just three weeks
later I had a custom suit waiting for me
and it fits great I get compliments on
it all the time great for my summer
weddings that I've been going to you can
shop online if you don't live near one
of the Indo Chino showrooms at Indo
Chino comm you can also of course go to
one of the showrooms if you do have one
nearby and this week my listeners and
viewers can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just three hundred and seventy
nine dollars at Indo Chino calm when you
enter the code Pakman at checkout that
is more than 50% off the regular price
for a premium made-to-measure suit
shipping is free Indo Chino kaam promo
code Pakman to get any premium suit for
379 plus free shipping a great deal for
a perfectly tailored suit